[Music]
welcome to the news eye and a surprise
move Saudi Arabia and Iran have
announced that they're resuming
diplomatic ties in a coup for China the
deal was struck in Beijing after four
days of secret talks it follows seven
years of hostility between the Saudi
Arabian Kingdom as it broke off official
relations with Tehran both countries
have pledged to reopen their embassies
within the next two months Iran's top
security official said the deal aims to
consolidate tehran's ties with Nations
across the Islamic world
we have been here in Beijing for six
days I held talks with my Saudi
counterpart that led to the agreement to
normalize relations we agreed with Saudi
Arabia to open a new page based on the
interests of the two countries and on
Regional security and to promote
stability instead of exacerbating
tensions we hope this will contribute to
the establishment of security and
development in the region and balance
the behavior of foreign powers and their
distance from our region to which they
came without permission we look forward
to this agreement contributing to the
consolidation of our relations not only
with Saudi Arabia but also with the
countries of the region and the Islamic
world the enemy especially the Zionist
entity feels frustrated and despaired by
this agreement
is standing by at the United Nations
Headquarters in New York as is our White
House correspondent Kimberly halket in
Washington DC but first let's chat to
Ali Hashem who's live for us into Iran
and let's just begin with what has been
agreed
well suhail what has been agreed is
restoring diplomatic ties between the
two countries that's been severed since
2016. that means in around two months
from now there is going to be a meetings
between the officials of the Islamic
Republic of Iran the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia and mainly officials in the
foreign Ministry and they will agree on
the road map to restoring uh relations
ambassadors will get back to the uh to
to both capitals Saudi ambassador to
Tehran Iranian ambassador to Riyadh and
also Reviving a 2001 security pact that
was essential at that time when it was
signed to Regional security both
countries are saying that they want this
deal to have its own impact on Regional
security and Regional Security will mean
also trying to contain uh the uh
escalation in Yemen the the war in Yemen
maybe situation in Lebanon that where
there is no president because of these
uh contradictions and clashes of
interests between Iran and Saudi Arabia
also this will have its own a reflection
on the situation in Iraq and probably
Syria also
in the hours that we've heard about this
news uh Alley we're getting the general
impression that Regional capitals in the
Middle East are surprised about this
announcement as most probably as many uh
as media organizations are as well I
mean what's the reaction from Baghdad I
know you've mentioned Iraq just now but
there must be surprise
well suhail interestingly this path
started in Baghdad in 2021 and continued
throughout 2022 former prime minister
Mustafa al-qadimir was the first to
mediate between the two countries even
even before Mr falcademy uh there are
the other Prime Ministers tried to do
that between the two countries but it
was during the Academy's time that
officials from Iran and Saudi Arabia met
for five times five rounds of talks in
Baghdad and also other sessions on
security levels in Oman but of course
for the Iraqis this this wasn't a
surprise with respect to the result but
it was a surprise with respect to the
timing no one thought that this is the
deal that everyone was talking about
everyone was thinking that a deal is
going to be between Iran and the United
States on a prisoner swap but not
between Iran and Saudi Arabia on
Reviving or restoring diplomatic
relations
thank you
well Iran and Saudi Arabia have long had
an adversarial history let's take a
quick look at some of those recent
events in 2011 Arab Spring saw protest
movements against these status quo in
several countries in the Middle East
Saudi Arabia accused Iran of inciting
protests in Bahrain against the royal
family Iran denied the accusation well
as the Civil War in Yemen began in 2015
Saudi Arabia backed the internationally
recognized government targeted houthi
Rebels strongholds now Iran was widely
accused of backing the houthis
militarily it said it provided political
support and in 2016 Saudi Arabia
executed a prominent Shiite leader who
supported descent against the kingdom
there was uproar in Iran where
protesters burnt parts of the Saudi
Embassy Riyadh then severed diplomatic
ties with Tehran and in 2019 Saudi
Arabia's state-run oil company was hit
by a houthi drone attack five million
barrels a day of crude production was
affected close to half of the Kingdom's
output and Iran denied any involvement
there
Let's cross over to James Bay's our
diplomatic editor at the United Nations
and let's say you know this is breaking
news really James we're all getting used
to this conversation that's been
developing and the news that's coming
out of the Middle East what's the
reaction Where You Are
well certainly the United Nations is
welcoming this the Secretary General uh
was briefed on it first thing this
morning as soon as the news emerged here
in New York and a very positive reaction
he believes that this could be good news
for the entire region we heard Ali talk
about uh the situation in countries like
Lebanon and Iraq Yemen I think is the
one where the UN will be most uh most
interested in this can they actually
bring the war in Yemen to a proper
negotiated settlement we have a very
uneasy truce that's been in place it's
nearly now eight years in the next few
days it'll be eight years since Saudi
Arabia intervened in Yemen and they've
been bogged down there ever since that
I'm sure is one of the motivations uh
from uh the Saudi side of course there
are important implications with regard
to Israel Israel is the one country I
think it is not going to like this they
had been hoping that the US would
persuade uh Saudi Arabia to join the
Abraham Accords uh get better relations
with Israel and completely isolate Iran
that's what prime minister Netanyahu
wants and it's not what he's going to
get I think the overwhelming thing that
I'm seeing from this is is is a very
different approach now to Saudi uh
foreign policy traditionally before
Muhammad bin Salman who now steers the
strategy for the Saudi Kingdom uh Saudi
Arabia very much was in the U.S camp on
everything but this deal it was brokered
today in China and at the same time the
Saudi foreign minister uh was in Russia
talking about his good relations with
Russia it's worth pointing out the Saudi
foreign minister also as recently in
Ukraine and they've offered themselves
as a mediator in that conflict but I
think Saudi Arabia now believes uh that
it can't just focus on the US it needs
to it needs to look at all of the
players in a multi-polar world
a developing story certainly from the
U.N Thanks James Bays our political
editor there thank you Kimberly Hal kit
joins us now from the White House our
White House correspondent Kimberly you
know as the news has been breaking you
know we've been trying to get reaction
from Washington they'll be dealing with
an issue of the of Saudi being a
long-term Ally in Iran being a long-term
adversary
yourself
yeah and speaking of adversaries the
White House seems to be somewhat
sensitive that it's other adversary
China is the one that seems to have
brokered this deal in terms of now the
resumption of of ties between Iran and
Saudi Arabia and when asked about this
the spokesperson John Kirby somewhat
sensitive when speaking with reporters
really pushing back on the assertion
that perhaps there is some waning
diplomatic power in the part of the
United States that usually it's the
United States that is brokering these
type of agreements or or uh sort of
understandings and really pushing back
on this saying that the United States
was welcoming this seeing it through the
lens of efforts to help end the war in
Yemen and de-escalate the tensions in
the Middle East and still acknowledging
though that it did not have a hand in
any of this and in fact though saying
that uh de-escalation and diplomacy is
still a key pillar of the Biden
administration's policies that they
brought to Saudi Arabia just last year
but at the same time admitting that they
were not in any way involved in the
discussions that ultimately brought
about this understanding between Saudi
Arabia and Iran
Kimberly helicopt there are White House
correspondent thank you for the update
Kimberly well joining me now here in the
studios of the Lizzy's Saga he's the
chairman of the gulf Research Center
welcome to Al Jazeera nice to have you
here sir can I just begin with asking
you could you from your knowledge and
your contacts within uh the Saudi
government explain practically how this
agreement is going to work and does this
mean the hostilities between the two
countries are now over well let's hope
that it will be over because the
agreement basically focus on the
respecting the national law the
agreement also talk about the Vienna
treaty with regard to the Diplomat and
political and
diplomatic facilities so that is also
important it talks about respect of the
sovereignty of the state which is very
important if we take all of this in
account and it says it's a new page so
basically what we are saying we are
trying to stop all the escalation go to
de-escalation now focus on the on the
unilateral relation that bring peace and
security to the region here and that
means no intervention on the domestic
affairs issues from Iran into Saudi
Arabia which is very important that it
has been a new report did talk about the
you know the various issues that has
been between Saudi Arabia and Iran in
the past but I think that's a positive
step you know it can look of course
there are lots of details in the future
that need to be looked out in other
words how is the implementation in Saudi
Arabia always concerned about the
interventionist policy the expansionist
policy of Iran the support of the
militia group the energy security the
maritime security so there are a key
issues and also including the escalation
in country like Yemen Lebanon Syria many
of the of the issues and we'll get into
that in a moment as well I mean how
delicate in your opinion and in your
knowledge were these negotiations they
were held quite secretly they were they
there were negotiations happening that
people knew about as we've heard from
various contributors and various
correspondents but the minute detail of
a potential reproachment between Tehran
and Riyadh has come as quite a surprise
especially with China involved no I
think I think the Chinese president when
he visits Saudi Arabia on the summit of
the Arab Gulf and Saudi Chinese Summit I
think it was clear when he stated that
he wanted to see a you know peace and
stability and Security in the region and
you want to see more constructive role
from Iran although Iran at that time did
not like it and they called the Chinese
Ambassador in Tehran
you know saying that they don't like
what they have heard but as soon as you
know the Iranian president visited uh
Beijing it was very important that the
message was delivered being the largest
partner of both sides I mean Saudi and
the gulf it's almost 130 billion dollar
with China so we're the largest trading
partner with with China There is almost
36 percent of China import of energy
comes out of the the gulf countries but
at the same time Iran is the is the the
biggest buyer of the Iranian energy is
is China so this is why there is a big
and interesting relation both and this
is why China had the leverage on the on
the on the uh
um also absence of Russia being very
busy with the with the Ukrainian crisis
China had the best there in terms of the
diplomacy that's been involved the
questions that are now arising are
knowing that China's mediated uh this
agreement between these two countries is
the position of countries like the
United States who've been long-term
allies of Saudi Arabia and whether they
are being pushed to one side replaced or
is it just that Saudi Arabia is looking
for other alternatives to find a
long-term way of cohabitating with its
neighbors as is Iran well unfortunately
the U.S did send some wrong messaging
before to the region here including
reallocation of the forces reducing
their involvement in the region asking
the region to uh not responding at the
time when we wanted the respondent news
report you talked about getting the oil
facility where we've lost half of our
oil production for a month yeah you see
there so all of that have have raised
the question is the U.S still the most
reliable uh partner that we can rely on
when it comes to the regional security
or also we need to keep our option open
when President Biden attended The Summit
in Jeddah he he wanted to see a big
condemnation against the the Russian and
also reducing uh uh uh you know the
relation with China but also getting out
of the object plus and increasing oil
production none of this had been
implemented and you know the region said
well we're no longer the same old boys
that you used to know I think here there
is a sort of an interest that we need to
protect both interests you have your
interest as the U.S and you have
interest as a legioneer and we need to
you know evaluate that and deal from
that angle instead of just being a
listener to what an implementer of your
wish list it would be interesting to see
what does happen in the coming months
for the moment
thanks so much for joining us here on
the Saturday uh in Doha thank you
well let's get the view on this from
Yemen now with Hussein he's in Sana he's
a pro who the journalist and joins us uh
good to have you with us on the program
can I just get your reaction to uh news
coming out to China about this new deal
between Iran and Saudi Arabia and how it
might impact and will impact Yemen
I don't think it will have any impact on
Yemen I mean we remember that when the
war started on Yemen on 26th of March
2000 and 2015 uh Saudi still had ties
with the Iran they only closed the
embassy in January 2016. so the
reopening of their Embassy or collusion
again in the nearby future it will not
actually affect Yemen's but as Muhammad
Abdullah the spoke person of ansarullah
he has committed made a comment about
this latest agreement between Saudi
Arabia and he said that the region
actually is in need for normal relation
to return between all Islamic and Arabic
and Nation especially in this region to
face together what he called the Zionist
and the American intervention in Yemen
which he said that intervention actually
invest in a dispute between a country
that's why here is an of course they
will welcome any agreement either
between Saudi Arabia there between Iran
between any other Arabic and Islamic
Nation but I think what will affect
Yemen's is the total lift of Saudi
blockade I just want to remind you that
we are coming close to enter the ninth
year of the Saudi war and bulucate on
Yemen which is on the 26th uh of March
of this month and I believe as I hear
from here that the Saudi Arabia have
these two weeks to show a good will and
to to reopen total opening of Sanaa
airport a totally opening of her data
port and as well to pay the salaries of
Yemen is of all yemeni civilians from
the the oil Revenue that is Saudi
actually is collected from selling
yemeni oil and I think let me just jump
in there let me just jump in there you
need to let me
jump in there you need to let me ask you
the questions because obviously there's
a lot to get through and I understand
where you're coming from and we've
allowed you to have your initial say we
need to also talk about the various
groups it's not just the houthis there
are other factions within uh Yemen that
are fighting this war to the East and to
the west and to the north do you think
the houthis is the largest group who
control the capital Center as one
contributor told us can actually get
these other groups on board
foreign
meeting an agreement between Yemen is
without any Saudi intervention but as
you mentioned these old groups they are
actually just a tools or authorities of
Saudi Arabia and United Arab Emirates
they are either fighting each other and
what is actually important for us and as
they say is it will be their main goal
is a total Liberation from Yemen and
this Liberation will be from any foreign
troops in Yemen and it will be from uh
to fight those troops who are actually
loyal to this intervention and
occupation on Yemen and that's why they
are really great but they have always
welcome any talk with any of these
groups uh either in the South or uh even
though the Muslim Brotherhood but they
should actually cut their ties with
Saudi Arabia or they should not be used
for uh for Saudi Arabia okay as a a
tools to destroy Yemen indeed I think
there's a lot of discussion talking and
negotiation to happen within Yemen
itself we shall see what happens
certainly in the two weeks that you're
talking about
thanks for joining us from Sana
plenty more ahead here on the Al Jazeera
NewsHour including